- Each of your weapons will now
be put through a series
of three tests, there
will be a strength
test, a sharpness test, and
up first, the kill test.
Doug?
Blade smiths, to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do, I
will take your rings,
and for slashes and thrusts
on this big carcass.
Rebel, you're up first.
You ready?
- More than ready.
Let's do this.
The amount of stress
in hitting that pig,
I'm afraid the rivets
may try to come loose.
[music playing]
[whacking]
(WHISPERING) Nice job.
All right.
I like the construction here.
It's unique.
I've never seen
this done before.
It makes it very
sturdy, but it adds
a little more weight to it.
It makes siding it a
little bit more difficult.
But yet, once you get going,
your winning fire will kill.
- Thank you.
- All right, Chuck.
Your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
For me, the big
concern is the welds.
That's the weak point.
[music playing]
[whacking]
It ain't critical.
Just like that one broke,
any of the other ones
could possibly break,
which has me worried
that I really
screwed something up.
[whacking]
First up, it's obvious.
The problem here is
you lost the blade.
With the welds that you
have here, it broke.
That's why you have other blades
to help out with the fight.
Your blades are wicked sharp.
Because they're so
much lighter, the cuts
are deeper and sharper.
It will kill.
Next stop, the strength test.
Dave?
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your wind and fire
rings, I'll be attacking
our bamboo woosh dummie.
Rebel, you're up first.
You ready?
Definitely.
[music playing]
[whacking]
Damn.
OK.
So right off, Rebel,
those points are wicked.
They are nice and
sharp and strong.
There's a lot of
weight to these blades.
But I think your construction
technique is brilliant.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Chuck.
You ready?
- Yeah.
OK
[music playing]
[whacking]
So Chuck, we have
lost another one.
They feel good.
They're light, they're
fast, they're sharp.
But they're coming apart.
So Chuck, the bottom line
is, with this kind of damage,
I can't safely
continue to test these.
I understand.
All right.
Chuck, now we have a vote of
no confidence from the judges
to move forward in this testing.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
- Thanks.
You put on a good fight.
I don't mind losing to Rebel.
He came up with a
brilliant design.
I may not have won, but I always
figured if I can get a good
it'll kill out of Dough, I won.
And I did.
And I'm pretty
excited about that.